lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
resolver algunos problemas de conversión
entre litros y mililitros y solo como
recordatorio mili significan una
milésima de modo que un mililitro es una
milésima de un litro otra manera de
pensar en esto es un litro es igual a
mil mililitros así que dicho lo anterior
cuantos mililitros son siete litros
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en esto bien
si un litro es igual a mil mililitros
entonces siete litros son lo mismo que
siete mil mililitros y 18 litros pausa
del vídeo y piensen en esto bueno es
igual a 18 mil mililitros 18 mil
mililitros la cantidad de litros que
tengas multiplicado por mil es igual a
los mililitros porque cada mililitro es
una milésima parte de un litro hagamos
más ejemplos aquí dice que espació
mililitros es igual a 15 litros pausa en
el vídeo de nuevo y tratan de resolverlo
recuerden que cada litro es igual
a mil mililitros de modo que 15 litros
es igual a 15 mil mililitros recuerden
que si tienen una unidad más pequeña
como ésta que es mil veces más pequeña
el número que obtendrán de la conversión
de una unidad más grande será un número
más grande aquí tenemos una unidad
pequeña por lo tanto tenemos una cifra
más grande
hagamos un ejemplo más compara con mayor
que menor que o igual que 9 litros como
son en relación con 90 mililitros pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolver lo
bueno cuántos mililitros son 9 litros 9
litros es igual a 9 mil mililitros y 9
mil mililitros claramente es mayor que
90 mililitros así que lo que tenemos que
hacer en un problema como éste es
convertir los dos lados en mililitros
9.000 mililitros que equivalen a 9
litros 9.000 mililitros es mayor que 90
mililitros terminamos